if someone says the name maimonides
there's no question which figure comes
up in the minds of most people
moses maimonides is one of the most
famous intellectuals in history and for
good reason his rationalist philosophy
and even more so his legal writings have
had an enormous impact on the
development of judaism but while he is
definitely a very fascinating figure
that is worth talking about and i know
that both zevi and justin are going to
be doing that in their videos there is
another maimonides there is to me
equally as interesting his son abraham
abraham maimonides not only succeeded
his father as the head of the jewish
community in egypt but also and in
contrast to his father's heavily
rationalistic philosophy
also became the figurehead of a
piatistic movement in egypt that was
heavily influenced by islamic mysticism
or sufism in their renunciant's
anaesthetical mystical practices so
while zevi and justin are doing their
normie videos about maimonides the elder
we're going to be cool and contrarian by
instead exploring the life and movements
of his son
[Applause]
as i just alluded to this episode is
part of a triple collaboration with the
channels esoterica and seekers of unity
both of their videos will be focusing on
the much more famous moses maimonides
and his relationship to the slippery
concept of mysticism so definitely go
check out their videos first or in
connection to this one
it really is a privilege for me to be
able to work with such amazingly
talented people both zevi and justin are
amazing scholars and fantastic people
and i again i am humbled by the fact
that i get to work with people that are
so inspiring so i really recommend you
go check out their channels and give
them some love i've seen their videos
and they're really amazing so go check
them out they're about the elder
maimonides who is so important for this
topic
it is indeed difficult to talk about
abraham maimonides without doing so in
connection to the incredible career of
his father
having come from al andalus or spain
originally maimonides the elder had fled
from his homeland to eventually settle
in fostat close to modern cairo in egypt
here he eventually became the leader of
the jewish community as he was not only
a greatly learned philosopher but also a
legal expert and authority on the
halacha the jewish law indeed his
probably most significant work from a
jewish point of view was his monumental
mishna torah a massive work that
attempts to basically go through the
entire jewish law and categorize it in
ways that had never been done before
in the more purely
philosophical sphere he is better known
for the work known as the mora nebuchim
or the guide for the perplexed in which
he presents his rationalistic
aristotelian influence philosophy
needless to say maimonides was already a
giant during his own lifetime and
even though he was controversial among
many he held a great deal of authority
his son abraham maimonides was born in
fostat in egypt in the late 1180s and
grew up watching his father perform his
various duties as physician to the
ayurved sultan saladin as a philosopher
and as the head of the jewish community
in the region taking on many visitors
and giving advice on matters on jewish
religion
he would have learned a lot from his
father being taught how to perform
communal duties rabbinic law science and
medicine and studying philosophy through
the guide for the perplexed and would
indeed inherit most of these roles upon
his father's death abraham himself
eventually also became known as the
nagid the head of the egyptian jewish
community just like his father was there
could be various reasons for this among
them probably the fact that his father
was so loved by many but he seems to
have had a reputation as a great legal
scholar and thinker himself even before
coming the raise or head of the
community jude al-harizi wrote about
abraham that he was called young in
years but great in knowledge a young man
who makes fools out of the wise
his role as leader wasn't uncontested
though and some prominent individuals in
egypt opposed it but it seems that he
could have been given this title as
early as 1205 when he would have been
only 19 years old and thus almost
immediately after his father's death in
many of the ways mentioned abraham
followed in his father's footsteps he
not only managed communal affairs for
basically all jews living in egypt but
also served as a physician to the ayubid
sultan a privileged job that also
allowed him to gain benefits for the
jews through his close relationship with
the ruling muslim elite on top of this
abraham also regularly worked at the
hospital in cairo tending to the sick
from all communities living there the
muslim medical chronicler ibn abu sabia
who also worked alongside abraham in the
hospital had this to say about him quote
he was a celebrated physician learned in
the art of medicine and skilled in its
practice he worked in the service of the
king el camille
he also frequently left the royal palace
to tend to the sick in the hospital in
cairo
i met him in cairo during my medical
appointment in the hospital in 631 or
632 and found him to be a tall gentleman
slender in built and refined in manners
elegant in conversation and outstanding
as a physician
in other ways however he diverged from
his father quite dramatically primarily
for the fact that he became the central
figure and head of a movement of jewish
pietism that sought to reform the
prayers of the jewish service the prayer
service as well as
perform certain renunciant and ascetical
practices that were heavily influenced
by the islamic mystics or sufis that was
so prevalent in this region at the time
abraham and his movement represent a
very fascinating time when the
coexistence of islam and judaism could
produce some really fascinating results
and provide us with a really cool
example of inter-religious influence and
dialogue albeit sometimes indirectly as
well as a general look into the world of
medieval judaism and islam so to fully
grasp this topic let's first get an
overview of this very significant time
and place this was a very eventful time
in various different ways politically
especially in egypt the ayubid dynasty
led by salah hidden or saladin had just
recently toppled the fatimids and a
smiley shi'i dynasty that had ruled the
region for centuries prior
the larger islamic world was ruled by
various small and large kingdoms the
abbasid caliphs in baghdad essentially
only being a symbolic authority at this
point in al-andalus the puritanical
al-muhads had just entered the scene
which was one of the main reasons that
maimonides the elder had to leave the
area and settled in a more welcoming
egypt jews lived all across the islamic
world at the time and thrived in many
ways except in certain places like
almohad spain that i just mentioned
there were jews living in muslim
majority regions as well as in europe
where christianity dominated and even
though there were contacts between these
groups we sometimes see them developing
separately in some unique ways
as always religions and cultures adapt
and change depending on the time and
place in which they find themselves and
this is true here as well as we will see
intellectually this was an insanely
vibrant time in which we see some of the
most major thinkers in history appearing
across different communities maimonides
thomas aquinas ibn arabi ibn rust and
many more sufism often called islamic
mysticism had started to really flourish
at around this time and was widespread
all across the islamic world to the
point of being essentially mainstream
and not long after the lives of the
maimonides we see the emergence of
kabbalah within judaism so this is an
incredibly fascinating time in which a
lot is happening on a number of fronts
and abraham maimonides pietest movement
is one significant result of this
sufism had become a significant part of
mainstream islam and was thus a very
visible and key feature of muslim
majority societies
their characteristic renunciation
practices and often very strict
devotional regimen proved very
inspirational to people across religious
borders already with the jewish figure
of bahia and pakuda we can see
influences from sufism finding its way
into judaism in his very significant
work entitled the duties of the heart he
presents spiritual and ascetic practices
that showcase clear influences from the
language and concepts of the sufis at
the time
bahia and his book represents a general
trend at the time one of an increased
popularity for asceticism and related
practices in the words of ras fishbein
quote jews from iberia to iraq in the
second half of the 12th and first half
of the 13th centuries increasingly drew
from sufi models of ascetic piety
including adopting supergratory prayers
strict regimens of fasting and solitary
retreats in the desert and mountainside
this seems to be corroborated by the
writings of moses maimonides himself who
refers to these individuals within the
jewish community at the time and mocks
them essentially for imitating the
practices of other nations and indeed
this was a major point of discussion as
well as one of the major controversies
surrounding the later movement that
would develop
the
very harsh response from some jewish
authorities that attacked people like
abraham and claiming that they had
adopted practices from other religions
like the muslims something that was not
allowed in the religion of judaism uh
and this is something that abraham
himself would respond to in some very
interesting ways and with all this said
it is interesting to note that there was
often a level of respect shown towards
some gentiles or other religious
communities at least in some ways the
already mentioned bahib and pakuda
claimed in his work to draw quote from
the saints and sages of every society
and philosophers like maimonides greatly
admired his muslim peers and partly as a
result of his influence the general
perspective that many jews would adopt
was one where on the one hand
christianity was often seen as
idolatrous heresy and as essentially
polytheism and on the other islam and
the muslims were at least respected for
the fact that they upheld a very strict
monotheism
about islam he writes quote the children
of ishmael have for their part adopted
this monotheistic faith from the
children of israel and have built the
foundation of their religion upon it
they have rejected the error and folly
of their ancestor who used to worship
idols and did not affirm the unity and
exaltedness of god's name as it is
written
called nations shall come to you from
the ends of the earth and say our
ancestors have inherited lies vanity
that is of no avail
and it is perhaps with abraham himself
the nagid or head of the egyptian jewish
community in the early 13th century that
we see the culmination of this increased
interest and tendency of islamic sufi
interaction and influence indeed his
pietist mystical movement serves as the
most daring and extreme example of this
religious dialogue one that became very
controversial to his core religionists
but what was this movement all about
what abraham or the nugget did was to
instigate a new devotional style both on
an individual
mystical level and in terms of communal
practices
there seems to have been an inner circle
of which abraham was the leader that
upheld a strict spiritual regimen one
that seemed very similar to the islamic
sufis these practices included the
emphasis on a teacher-student
relationship the importance of having a
sheikh that could teach you
the ways of the path as well as intense
fasting during the days and nightly
vigils in which one would pray for long
periods of time
so the pietist would fast during the day
and then neglect sleeping by instead
spending most of the night in additional
prayers furthermore there seems to have
been an emphasis on individual
meditation and contemplation and even
pietists going on spiritual retreats or
khalwa in arabic where they would spend
40 days in complete solitude focusing on
prayer and meditation these renuncians
and ascetic practices had the aim of
purifying the soul and to eventually
instigate a mystical illuminative
experience thus according to abraham
perfecting the jewish devotional life
and even having prophetic and messianic
implications as we will see later this
was quite unusual for the jews at the
time this focus on individual solitary
meditation and prayer seem to go against
the very common
idea within mainstream judaism that
emphasizes the importance of communal
practices and communal prayers in the
synagogue for example abraham and his
group didn't neglect these aspects of
religion of course and they even engaged
themselves with trying to reform the
practices in the synagogues the communal
prayers and the way that they were
performed as we will see later but these
this emphasis that abraham put on
mystical contemplative practices did
become quite controversial to some as we
saw this wasn't completely new within
judaism with the figure of bahid and
pakoda serving as a good example of
similar tendencies in earlier periods
but it was a break with the common
practices in the region at the time the
pietists around abraham maimonides
performed spiritual exercises of
solitary prayer and meditation coupled
with strict rules of fasting and
asceticism all under the guidance of an
experienced teacher the intimate details
of these practices are hard to get at
since there is after all a level of
esotericism around it given the role of
the spiritual guide to disclose these
teachings we do know that abraham
suggested that practitioners prepare a
separate part of one's house and which
one can be alone and which is dedicated
to these practices in particular prayers
would have been performed while sitting
on the knees as well as while standing
we also know that music was sometimes
involved in some way indeed music was
seen as an important and useful tool to
arouse spiritual states and help orient
the soul during these practices
abraham encourages the pietists to
recite prayers in a harmonious melody
and musical instruments may have been
employed in some way too just like his
father he connects the use of music with
prophecy and the biblical prophets in
pointing out its usefulness he writes
quote in order to attain solitude that
leads to communion with god
the prophets and their followers used
musical instruments and melodies seeking
to arouse the faculty towards god may he
be exalted and to empty the mind of
anything but him
he points to the fact that many of the
biblical prophets of ancient times in
israel would use music and musical
instruments to induce states in which
they would receive their prophecies and
this connection of practices to biblical
presidents becomes very important for
abraham indeed as we have pointed out on
multiple locations and as many of you
have probably noticed a lot of these
practices are very similar to some of
the key features of sufism as it existed
in the islamic world at the time
many of the rabbinic authorities of the
time accused the pietist movement of
heresy and of copying and adopting
practices from a gentile religion islam
something that was forbidden in jewish
law but abraham had a clear response to
this criticism while it is difficult for
us to deny that there must have been
some influence from the sufi movement at
this time and abraham
doesn't deny that to the full extent but
he does claim that these practices
aren't really taken from the sufis
instead they represent ancient israelite
practices that had been lost after the
exile period in babylon the only reason
that there are similarities between what
the pietists were doing and the sufis is
that the sufis had somehow discovered or
preserved a tradition that was
originally jewish or israelite thus they
are not imitating islam but simply
reviving the original true israelite
devotion this argument is stressed even
more as similar controversies erupt
around abraham's
prayer reforms so synagogue prayer
reforms remember he wasn't just the peed
or a leader of the pietist movement he
was also the
head of the jewish community in egypt
more generally and when it comes to
communal practices in synagogues abraham
saw a lot that he wanted to change here
too he complained of the disorderly
nature of these affairs with people
sitting along the walls of the synagogue
compare this to the muslims who by
comparison appeared much more organized
standing in perfect rows and praying in
complete unison
abraham wanted to reform these communal
practices in the synagogue too in ways
that seem to bring them a lot closer to
the customs of the muslims while he
never seemed to have actually
implemented these changes on a communal
level it is clear that this was his
eventual aim his reforms included that
the jews would stand in orderly rows and
do things like bowing and even full
prostration with the forehead to the
ground something that was entirely
associated with islamic prayers and not
with jewish practice for this reason he
was again attacked and heavily
criticized by many authorities in the
jewish community who felt that he was
again adopting gentile practices into
judaism
his response to this was exactly the
same he wasn't imitating the muslims he
was simply reviving the ways that the
israelites would have prayed in
pre-exiled times and providing biblical
support for his claims he says quote be
careful in this matter not to confuse a
new idea in custom with ancient ones
that have been neglected to the point of
being forgotten and only later brought
to the attention of the community
restored and revitalized this is the
case in the matter concerning us here
that of prostration which we are now
discussing for prostration is an
obligation of the law and ancient custom
of the people a fact neglected over the
course of many years in exile and when
one has been made aware that it is an
obligation and thus puts it into
practice it appears to be deluded and
ignorant as it was a religious
innovation
it is an innovation only in relation to
the intermediate time in which it was
defunct not in relation to the time of
the original community
it is really interesting that in his
defense of these prayer reforms and in
the mystical practices of the pietists
he seemed to kind of affirm the common
narrative of the muslims which is that
the practices and ideas of islam is the
original version of you know judaism
that has been forgotten later by the
jewish community that isn't exactly what
abraham is saying he's saying that the
muslims have
adopted some of those practices and
ideas that were present in the israelite
community but the idea is very similar
could this be another result of him
living in muslim-dominated lands and
interacting with the intellectual world
of islam and its ideas
it's possible but he also seems very
convinced of his ideas and bases a lot
of it in scripture as we saw it is an
absolutely fascinating example of
inter-religious influence and dialogue
now this should not be taken as some
kind of indication of a lacking
commitment to judaism abraham was fully
convinced that he was reviving true
judaism as the true religion of god
through the practices of the pietists
that he saw as having resurrected he saw
a way of perfecting jewish worship and
restoring it to its original pre-exile
form
and this had significant messianic
implications
while moses maimonides is often upheld
as a paragon of reason and as a critic
of mysticism many of his later ideas
proved quite fruitful for later mystical
speculation including for his son
abraham he shared his father's idea of
prophecy as a perfection of the human
spirit and a resulting quote overflow
overflowing from god to the intellectual
and imaginative faculties of the person
so a prophet is a person who has
perfected these faculties the
intellectual and imaginative to such a
degree that he experiences an
illumination or revelation from god but
doesn't this sound like basically anyone
can become a prophet well yes that's
exactly what abraham and his associates
thought
by reviving the ancient original
practices of the israelites including
the meditative and mystical practices
that they adopted one could open up the
floodgates of prophecy once again in
other words one could enter into a new
era when prophecy was once again
possible in essence abraham defines
prophetic experience as identical to the
highest forms of mystical experience the
final step on the ladder of spiritual
ascent
as you can tell this is quite a
different view of prophecy than what
some are used to from a religion like
islam but to the pietists it was
entirely in line with jewish teachings
this may sound familiar to those of you
who have encountered the jewish mystic
and capitalist abraham abulafja who
lived at roughly around the same time a
little bit later he too was a devoted
follower of maimonidean philosophy but
developed a form of prophetic kabbalah
where the goal of his complex mystical
practices was a cleaving or union a
devote to god or the active intellect an
experience that he too defined as
prophetic in nature to abulafja the
ultimate aim which was reachable through
his kabbalistic techniques was prophecy
and in the pietist movement in egypt the
idea seems to have been rather similar
to this
all the practices that we have talked
about the fasting nightly vigils
meditation seclusion and prayer had the
aim of striving for the mystical
prophetic goal under the guidance of a
teacher the spiritual wayfarers or
salikun will traverse on the ladder of
purification until they reach the
highest stage or station of perfection
what abraham often refers to as wasul or
literally arriving in arabic here they
will experience the overflow of
illumination upon the soul from god
quote
the soul will perceive a grandeur which
will dazzle it to a point where its
existence will be effaced thereupon the
soul will find itself bathing in the
presence of an overwhelming light called
the light of divine majesty the soul
will then perceive the mysteries
appearing within this light and this is
prophecy
this experience as the quote suggests is
identified with prophecy
is thus something that is reachable by
those who travel on the mystical path
under a legitimate teacher and perhaps
something that at some point everyone
will get to experience
quote the ultimate end or perfection of
the soul consists in the conjunction of
the human intellect with the angelic
realm of separate intellect both in the
intellectual apprehension that occurs
after death and in the imperfect
perception glimpsed in this life we can
see in the teachings of abraham
maimonides and the pietist movement the
fascinating ways that different
spiritual and religious traditions could
influence each other during the middle
ages abraham maimonides stands in the
shadow of his father and in spite of
this remains probably one of the most
interesting figures of his time the
spiritual practices and mystical ideals
of the movement gives us a glimpse into
the ways that
islam and sufism could influence judaism
but also into the diversity of judaism
itself we often tend to place all forms
of jewish mysticism under the banner of
kabbalah but here with the pietist
movement we arguably see an example that
we could
probably call
mystical or mysticism
with
keeping in mind the fact that this is a
very problematic term and nonetheless
here we see an example of what we could
call jewish mysticism that does not fall
under the category of kabbalah what is
also not worthy is the role of the great
moses maimonides in all of this while he
had nothing to do with the pietus
movement as such as far as we know we
can see that abraham and his associates
employ the great philosopher's teachings
to argue for some of their most lofty
mystical ideas his teachings on the
intellect and the human being's
relationship to it as well as those
surrounding prophecy among other things
provided some of the basis for the
pietists and their doctrines similarly
when we look at someone like abulafja
the same is true he also employs
mammadian teachings as central parts of
his heavily mystical theories indeed the
entire philosophical basis of these two
movements come from maimonides in some
way
this might seem ironic to some who share
the idea of maimonides at the great
enemy of mysticism and champion of
reason now this idea has started to be
at least a little challenged by some and
remains a very interesting debate the
question of maimonides relationship with
mysticism is not something that i will
answer here i'll leave some of that to
justin and zeby but it is interesting to
point out that the heavily rationalistic
philosophy of this intellectual giant
became central parts of some of the most
prominent mystical movements of the time
from the pietest movement of his son
abraham to the prophetic kabbalah of
abulafja and speaking of which don't
forget to check out the companion videos
posted by esoterica and seekers of unity
to amazing channels and good friends of
mine who will be tackling maimonides the
father you know what to do go subscribe
watch their videos and tell them that i
sent you i hope this was an interesting
look into a fascinating movement in
medieval judaism you can look forward to
more episodes on topics related to this
i'll probably be making videos about
moses maimonides 2 eventually but also
various topics within judaism jewish
mysticism
kabbalah and all things like that that
we all love to to explore and and talk
about i would as always like to extend
my deep gratitude to all the patrons who
support this channel
without whom none of this would be
possible and especially a shout out to
some of the new arrivals including nash
return
thank you all so much for watching i
look forward to seeing what you have to
say in the comments
don't forget to check out zevi and
justin's videos and i will see you next
time
[Music]
you